quite a contrast from last year the
annual state of the European Union
address was delivered with much optimism
Tania's since vices truck your economics
finally bouncing back and with our
confidence
the wind is back in your face
the EU is on its fifth year of economic
recovery and eurozone unemployment is at
a nine year low a key message Europe is
open for business but must always defend
its strategic interests yes Anya so bill
tundle
August on our yard some shoots ins
rockin industry and some shoots the
surcharge standards in the rotation on
yon see a lot aspirins assuage Rattata
commercially but abbiamo defended it
seemed as use to the cheated in in
essence free trade that respects europe
social standards without resorting to
protectionism EU growth plans don't
create jobs its businesses to create
jobs eight million jobs have been
created since Janka took office but it
hasn't all been plain sailing don't
divert news of automata in your popular
de Bruijn autocratic stories effective
political austerity 20 impose your pep
policies that have been criticized to
making it harder for people to make ends
meet not a bitter saga days of may - you
here to share tools possibility HD
Quebec Finnick Odair to comply opus
cannula TSN the man may attend Makati to
less as Europe continues to plot its way
forward come March 2019 there will be
one less Member State all I can say is
thank God we're leaving but you've
learned you've learned nothing for
brexit but recent election victories of
pro EU politicians have ignited a
newfound zeal to reform Europe into one
that's more attuned to the needs of its
citizens it is now now or never I should
say like in the song to build up that
European Union that the people are
asking for Shama convened e-k questo
parlamento
vas a ver Amenti dar un contribute o
determinant Allah Krishna the Union Army
or amento tyranny para la barrera in
Somali ultra East Eruzione in simi para
comprar tutelary form a necessary the
main political groups welcome to Yonkers
call for a union of freedom equality and
rule of law
[Music]